can they be humble one of the things I
love to do with the potential hire is to
invite him to a meal and watch how they
interact with a way it's an important
lesson you know we have a store
downstairs I just told Mike you guys are
working over a hardware store we have a
door store downstairs
that that store is only successful
because of the kids have put on the
orange apron and they need to be beat
they need to be made to feel that their
is important as I am or bernie is our
authoress and we always worked at that
the three of us so I think humility will
get you a hell of a lot more than you
Burruss and so I look for somebody who
is really outstanding but who doesn't it
exude I know I'm not staying rather or
shucks or gee thanks a lot or I'm so
glad you with us we couldn't have done
it without you I'm not a self-made man
all these little things where the person
you're trying to get the best out of is
comfortable and knowing that if he does
do his best you're okay with it and you
can't be that way if you have a level
for yourself so high that you don't
think everybody in that can we have
360,000 associates every single one of
the matters every single one and in the
summertime when we go up to five four
hundred and eighty thousand that's the
seasonality those eight 120,000 are
critical to our success because it's
busy and people want to get in and get
out they want to buy their plants they
want to buy their garden tools they
wanted a home work so you put somebody
on the floor the more knowledgeable in
the wor forthcoming they are the more
helpful they going to be the more
helpful they are the quicker the
customer gets in and out of the store
and that's important